to fight the recession the central banks
are flooding the market with cheap money
the fat is continuing to focus on its
zero rate policy and the european
central bank has cut its interest rate
to 0.5 percent but can this really help
the european countries and crisis that's
what i'm talking about with stephen
schneider from deutsche bank research
mr. Schneider you're analyzing the most
important economies around the world how
did the global economy perform in the
last month in a career if you look at
the day Beck's we can see that after
recovering between november and februari
this year it has dropped for the second
time in a row and it's now standing at
point 2 which is slightly above its
average why is that where can the
effects prime if we look at the
developments in the different areas
contributing to the day weeks basically
it has been weakness all over the place
the indicators dropped in the US and
Europe and in Asia the european central
bank has cut its interest rate to 0.5
percent can this really help the crisis
countries in europe now the measure
itself which is 25 basis point will
probably have a negligible impact but
you have to see the level is extremely
low it has been extremely on for quite
some time with 0 point 5 also other
measures like the liquidity provision
and most importantly the OMT program the
promise under certain conditions to buy
government bonds and an unlimited
quantity for from countries in trouble I
mean this has helped financial markets
quite a bit so it's supporting and
helping to stabilize the economy but you
have to see that we have quite some
headwinds coming from from fiscal and
private sector consolidation so the ECB
and I mean mr. Draghi has been quite
frank on that one has been doing
whatever it almost what what what it can
you know which is in line with its men
dead and I even there it has stretches
men that quite a bit but there is little
monetary policy can do when top of that
so it's just a stabilization and
stimulating is a different topic what
could stimulate the economy in Rio
Europe right now I mean it's it's very
hard to see as long as we don't you know
go down the route of the Bank of Japan
you know trying to double money supply
over just one or two years it I think
monetary policy again there there are
certain limits fiscal policy again I
mean it's it's clear that we are still
on the consolidation part deficits are
our have to be reduced although we have
seen that the Commission has given
France and Italy two years more time to
get the deficit below the three percent
threshold so that helps a little bit but
there is no quick fix we have to do
reforms I think what the politicians
especially if you look at countries like
Italy so they have to come up with
credible governments and incredible
policies to maintain market confidence
but it's it's it's a long uphill battle
we will talk about these reforms later
on in our focus interview this month we
talked about ways and means to stimulate
the economy in Europe you can watch the
full interview on www dwe english / mate
in germany